NARRATOR: It's the Sam Simon and
its crew that are confronting
the issues here head on.
Of course, their day
was a bit frustrating
when you see this overwhelming
amount of nets that's out
there, that there's
till the fishermen
going out and laying more nets.
NARRATOR: The Sam
Simon's primary weapon
in their fight
against these gillnets
is what they call a phantom ray.
The ray is set for
seven, eight meters.
NARRATOR: The ray is dropped
into the water at a set depth.
It drags a grappling
hook along the sea floor.
When the hook catches a
net, a thin breaker line
attached to the ship snaps.
This releases the ray and marks
the net's location with a buoy.
MAN (ON RADIO): Sam Simon,
Sam Simon, this is Viking.
I can confirm for the net.
I reckon there's a couple
of totoaba in the water there.
There must be six, seven
carcasses of totoaba
floating by us right now.
I guess the deal
is that they cut
the bladders out as
quick as possible
and throw the rest in the sea.
Now we're going
to launch the boat
and go find out whether it is
a totoaba net, or a long line,
or any illegal fishing gear
that is in these waters.
And then we're going
to retrieve it.
- Can I come with you?
- Of course.
The sea shepherd team
have managed to scoop
up the remnants of that net.
And we're on our way to
find out what's in it.
Surrounded by dead
carcasses of totoaba
that have been mutilated,
its twin bladders taken out.
They're everywhere.
PIA KLEMP: One, two.
Wow, that's tough, huh?
PIA KLEMP: Yeah, one, two.
NARRATOR: But the totoaba
are far from the only victims
of these nets.
And the nature of the sea, there
could be anything in this net.
We have been finding
everything from sea lions
to dolphins to
hammerhead sharks.
Not too long ago,
we saw a whale.
And it was almost
like an hourglass
for how much the
net was strangling
the whale like halfway through.
So it really is a whole load
of species that are caught up
in this trade for the totoaba.
Right?
The net doesn't
really distinguish
who it's going to catch.
So whichever animal swims
through these waters
is sentenced to death.
Oh, here comes the shark.
PIA KLEMP: Oh, no.
GIACOMO GIORGI:
Oh, the hammerhead.
Oh, Chris, it
feels pretty soft.
GIACOMO GIORGI:
Is it still alive?
PIA KLEMP: I don't think so.
Come here, baby.
We are wiping out sharks
from our oceans for their fins.
In Asia, they eat
shark fin soup.
And what happens is that
a lot of fishing vessels
catch a shark, cut
their fin, and then
throw back their bodies.
And finding a dead shark, a
dead hammerhead in this net
is really heartbreaking.
NARRATOR: But the
heartbreak here isn't
reserved for marine life alone.
As the Sam Simon
continues its mission
to remove illegal gillnets, the
nearby fishing towns suffocate.
[music playing]